[Music]
one of my favorite ingredients in the
world sums up food at its finest and
most prestigious caviar
very decadent very nutty very creamy
and it's bursting with flavor like
individual pearls exploding in your
mouth absolutely delicious
but classic wild caviar is under threat
sturgeon and the caspian sea are
overfished and close to extinction so
the hunt is on to find alternatives fast
so i'm looking for something sustainable
and affordable to blow beluga out of the
water when it comes to taste and texture
i'm not gonna find it in [ __ ]
knightsbridge
i've come to andalusia in southern spain
which for the past 25 years has hidden
one of the mediterranean's best kept
secrets
if this caviar is as good as the real
mccoy the proper beluga then this could
be a [ __ ] amazing find here in spain
it's the water flowing through these
mountains that led the owners of rio
frio caviar to set up a farm here after
a seven year search for the perfect
source
export manager and fellow brit keith
jaggart will be showing me around hi
gordon how are you nice to meet you
right now are you on a half term you
look about 12.
now i didn't think it's possible to farm
sturgeon why here in the middle of
[ __ ] spain of all places the
temperature of the water is 13 to 15
degrees all year round and that's
because we have the source of the spring
at 200 meters away from where we're
standing drinkable drinkable and natural
which is a benefit to the sturgeon of
course so are we talking about as good
as wild or better
i i'd say better you've got a big pair
of cohounders you know that i think
honest yes
first keith's taking me to see the
tiddlers
that's so ugly yeah yeah so delicious
and delicate yeah
but it'll be eight years before we can
tell the little boys
from the big money girls
who can be anything up to the age of 20
before their caviar's ready for
harvesting
oh god they're everywhere
but first i've got to catch one if you
can grab the head
[Music]
prehistoric distant relatives of the
shark these big mothers are almost 60
kilos and to be examined for caviar
they're wrestled out of the water by
hand let's get on
it's absolutely beautiful so how old is
this one this one would probably be
between
18 19 years old
for nearly half that time the valuable
eggs in this fish have been developing
their size and condition are checked
using ultrasound
you can just about see every single
egg i miss honestly identical to going
with your wife for an ultrasound little
ky jelly robin round
looking for a little heartbeat and i'll
ship there's two hard [ __ ] there
you've got twins except here we're
looking at what four and a half to five
kilos of caviar the trick is to catch
the eggs at their optimum quality before
the fish spawns naturally
but this beauty isn't quite ready yet
possibly six months right we'll give it
another another scan right and see how
it's getting on if we just try and turn
her around yeah come on okay oh [ __ ]
okay
and then just slowly push it off just
just very very calmly
when the sturgeon are ready they're
killed and sent for a clinical
extraction
[Music]
this looks like a [ __ ] operating
theater hola
today chief sturgeon surgeon javier is
entrusting me with the scalpel
is that too deep
again that's good just keep going a
little bit that's perfect
okay let me see oh [ __ ] i can see caviar
yeah it starts very far down i wish you
told me jesus christ look at all that
caviar in there
look at that
is that all the way up there my god okay
so you can actually see look at that
jesus christ you see the amount of eggs
there look at all the caviar it's like a
bathtub full of [ __ ] cabbage how much
is in there i'm surprised you haven't
got a security guard for each sturgeon
in there you know that
do you mind have a little taste please
no go ahead
unbelievable
it does need some salt on there
in terms of flavor
[ __ ] how
it's extras like a treasure
i couldn't wait to learn how to
transform these freshly harvested eggs
into the delicacy i know and love
so shall we process process
[ __ ] me now i'm going back home [ __ ] me
see you later
first the eggs are separated from the
membrane
so you're just gently rubbing it holding
the membrane and we're not bursting the
eggs like
this that is beautiful
what's that worth in there now keith
talking well over 10 000 pounds oh my
god
they're then rinsed in cold salted
spring water
before sea salt is added to dramatically
enhance the caviar's flavor you do i
don't want to [ __ ] up the 10 grams
okay fingers in and just last right here
faster faster okay
[Music]
very creamy
for me it doesn't need any more salt
that's delicious
seasoned to perfection and matured for
four months the caviar in this tin alone
will be worth three and a half grand
thank you thank you i'm pretty good yes
yes this stuff really does give wild
caviar a run for its money and i've got
the perfect recipe to show it off
right lobster potato salad with the most
amazing mayonnaise and that special
farmed caviar
tie two lobster towels with string as
the lobster cooks tail stays nice and
straight coat for six to seven minutes
bay leaf lemon lime fennel star on his
coriander bang
pop all the potatoes whilst that's
cooking mayonnaise
add mustard powder and white wine
vinegar to the egg yolks
whisk whisk whisk slowly add the olive
oil if we don't whisk it enough it
splits now to the exciting part a little
bit of truffle oil two or three little
drops beautiful
lobster out
it's nice and straight so it's a lot
easier to slice slice the potatoes
season and drizzle with olive oil
saute the potatoes and give the lobster
a blast of heat in the pan
literally 30 seconds each side that
stops the lobster becoming really chewy
and enhances the flavour
lightly dress the salad and serve five
nice slices of potato five nice
medallions of lobster a teaspoon
of truffle mayonnaise on the potato
finishing the salad with this baby look
at that
absolutely amazing my god it has to be
the perfect dish for the last supper
a salad of potato lobster truffle
mayonnaise and the most amazing [ __ ]
caviar
you